welcome to this video playing darun 94
who is that in precisely Darius votes
yeah he's not 17 years old anymore of it
it's a very good very good polish
Grandmaster in the world junior champion
at one time and I also featured um I
think one or two of his games in my in
my book I was really impressed he's very
good player so yeah I think he didn't
again much yellow rating recently maybe
he's concentrating more on studies or
something like that I can only speculate
there but he was gaining rating points
very very quickly some some years ago
but still seems to be in the low 2600 um
okay so i was preparing the fianchetto
let's do that
it's useful to recognize that the bishop
is not badly placed on d 7 it would help
if it was on um on b7 let's say okay I'm
going to go for the trade yeah it's
certainly not a bad idea trading the
strong willow pass Bishop one idea that
just came to my attention as some may be
queen should be eight attending a five
that could be an interesting idea let's
let's do that I mean a little bit like I
saw an idea and went for him go for it
immediately but yeah anyway maybe that's
an interesting idea of a five trying to
clarify maybe he wants to go for a quick
d4 here is at the point no so then what
about a five is that is that something
or is it is it rubbish he takes it night
takes
red fields of K takes b5 Queen takes
interest anal queen isn't activated but
if it takes Knight eggs I'm in some kind
of fork but some kind of pin I'm sorry
yeah okay I'm going back keeping my
rooks connected with a five possibility
is still in the position the book wasn't
well placed there anyway so now if I go
a five he takes it a couple of times c4
no I check on a four that's not helping
him much but it takes won't be 5 25 °c
for I have night takes before that also
doesn't seem too too bad B takes Knight
takes Knight takes rook takes you four
so that's the point it's not working
that's bad but it is it still I still
like the idea so let's prepared queen is
not so bad on b7 anyway can i still not
play that it's annoying really you have
an idea and it's not working if i go 85
and takes on b5 queen cheeks 95 95 be a
five
and then now I can take on a two
actually so it should work let's do it
hopefully I'm not miscalculating it
probably losses I me and now that's the
kind of thing I that that you really
shouldn't overlook it's very simple just
below below and you go from a normal
position to a bad one in very short
order what a hold of ya a5 is just gone
that was the idea simply look to a one
chap and the position is immediately bad
really bad
yeah yeah that's a really stupid you I
can just stay in that position and I
don't know why it may be as a slight
edge but it's nothing nothing
spectacular just a normal position ok
maybe maybe you if he has to take on g5
maybe that is some counter plane I mean
not enough but some
yeah courage and even calculating worse
than usual which makes it kind of
terrible
I Scott look a seventh Wells Fargo like
see sexy Scot rook a second that's the
additional problem and it's n95 playing
against against the pawn would be would
be nice on 23 but no evil is aiming for
possible 95 okay if it takes it here 95
is so not that bad takes Knight be sour
look on the 7th um I don't know maybe
you can just play see for you it's not
what you wanted I know I can take that
actually because of the back rank haha
tactic see what I can even take with the
Queen that's funny
so my morning 596 okay i don't think
that this helps anyway five rules
maybe I can get rid of that noise and
ice got from 97 coming like here maybe
four nights you form back again
okay no uh yeah okay that was a
ridiculous landing resigned of course he
can take with the rook is much better of
course also ah yeah okay I was a bad
game anyway I was I had this idea with a
five and I was really trying to make it
work and it just does not work very
simply it's not working yeah so I just
have to play them I don't know any move
that does not play a five nothing
particularly bad happening to me the
engine wants to do this for example
night / 26 that's just a normal position
nothing happening yeah why does a bit
better but it's nothing nothing terrible
yeah that's just not working very simply
the engine actually says that this okay
this is a different version of the whole
thing yeah that's bad if you if you
cannot calculate such simple stuff then
you will lose almost every game against
the good player right here here I'm just
lost she didn't make any particular
mistake maybe you can't play it better
but the engine is never really
criticizing any of his moves I just play
badly you played well what can you do
okay off to the next game thanks for
watching